well hello there
fans of family and friends of the dead
I'm Greg
I am Anita Anita and I have been sitting
around here waiting for the guardians of
the galaxy volume 2 trailer to drop this
is the truth of the jump in the Jimmy
Kimmel show and we're here now we are
that has dropped it is drops when you
see any of the guardians part two
trailers I have not seen any of them
actually okay you mean the movie has
seen a movie I've seen the movie one
time to act it's the only Marvel movie I
loved it but I saw one I said a couple
of the other guardians ago yeah yeah but
it is like the final one Wow okay so
this is the money shot right yeah nice
let's do this I'll be ready it'll be
here anyway
get a rifle you know where rifle of same
sort were you thinking gun for mine but
I
[Music]
you know they told me you people were
conceited douchebag I'm using my wrong
[Music]
yeah we're really gonna be able to jack
up our price it was I
I
[Music]
sometimes good thing you're searching
for your whole life let's write your - I
all right
[Music]
[Music]
Samiha
after all these years I've found you and
who the hell are you I'm your dad Peter
ah corrupt ah I gotta see him we finally
got it oh yeah yeah that was badass man
oh my god that whole trip I mean I've
made a lot of commentary on this movie
through many videos so I don't want to
keep repeating myself I just think it's
great at the marketing of this trailers
not really revealing what this films
actually about yeah I feel like it was
more directed towards the visuals like
the eye candy and there was so much more
of it so much I mean it really just went
all out a lot of like there were so many
things going on and it was hard to kind
of keep focused but I like that I think
it's very chaos like chaotic and happily
chaotic I guess bass kinetic energy
throughout and this seems like a
crazy-ass adventure looks like they're
all over the place yeah it's concluding
a lot of also space tropes that I like I
love any of those like any time it's a
series where they're like actually in
space and they're flying and it's like
they have a helmet on that alone in the
grand space yes that that's a really
cool but I love that I have it in there
the [ __ ] comedy is is so yeah like
strong they're gonna the characters in
this guy so the whole area there and it
looks like they're building more of like
a bond between them it's a vibe I got
from the trailers that they're actually
making them like family like that
they're creating that relationship
between the characters that is something
that's like gonna resume very little
more for everything no yeah there's so
much to look forward to I mean the
action was straight the comics gray we
all want to everyone loves baby Groot
I know raccoons hilarious as always well
nebula yondu are officially a part of
the guardians of the galaxy now and the
first one they were kind of an
antagonist and then this one it's like
oh they made them here's and they seem
like a good fit for it yeah they seem
like they're like that awkward they're
trying to find their place in the family
but there's a little awkward and a
little bit of a tension there between
the characters so that's nice it's going
to be nice which can still make for some
of the buy that we got from the first
one where it's like these are strangers
and they have to work together at CSIS
amanada they they were
pass that we're not repeating that with
the original Guardian because now it's
like them like you said earlier like
them forming more of a bond now you can
have that kind of interaction and banter
with those guys yeah I read about who
cooker rustles characters based on like
it is star-lord father but I'm gonna
have many months ago and I don't
remember the details brush it look at
all your ways because I gotta bring out
that we might see him that's crazy yeah
I wasn't expected but I think he's like
a planet
he's like a planet or something being
but in the movie they've obviously tamed
that and toned that down to something a
little bit different he's still playing
a character named ego just I'm glad I
didn't go with like what I read before
like or else is gonna be a voice like
that's what I thought yeah verse read it
but I'm so much happier we'll get to see
Kurt Russell Manny my little like phase
know you've got us are you kidding me
your navy shop I am a rough town bees
yes parts of the 92 yeah do you
appreciate him from the eighties Big
Trouble in Little China Jack in that
[ __ ] now that guy was like signature
beer that he he's a rocking in there
yeah he's a great addition to the other
character we haven't seen at and we
haven't seen the treasurer's data
Sylvester Stallone who's in this movie -
yeah okay so why was this interesting
they didn't put him in the trailer
because he would be a staple you know
you think yeah they buy raw oyster yeah
I guess either way man I mean this
trailer was [ __ ] sweet I thought I
thought it was I thought it was so much
fun it looks like the adventure are
there they taught themselves in terms of
exploration yeah because you know the
first ones like you do get it see this
cool space prism what they're fugitives
so they have they can't just be
everywhere curious like though they're
gonna go in your angry way out and
Alexander they're like the official
guardians of the galaxy now now it's not
just a comment said by a villain that
was supposed to be derogatory what's
interesting is like the first guardians
of the galaxy felt so separate from all
the other Marvel movies if I'll you
didn't need all these tie-ins and it
felt like it's just its own thing yeah
amazing and great it didn't feel like a
typical moral sense it has some of the
most high buck feel towards the upcoming
infinity war because it it really delved
a little bit delve more into the
Infinity stones it's featured
more and here I'm not getting any sense
of it linking to Avengers infinity war
but something tells me I like how the
first one didn't feel like it's just a
tie-in movie and didn't feel like it's
all about connecting a novel film that's
the answer but I feel like this one will
go out of its way a little more to make
maybe an image maybe towards the end of
the film or something to war natures
linked because yeah the gardens are
going to be infinity war but I do like
the connections I like when they know
the connections are yeah yeah I honestly
didn't know they weren't even make it to
anything that was going to be a thing I
was satisfied with the movie and I know
the baby Groot was like a little bit of
a like maybe that'll be a sue but I was
a satisfying feeling at the end of the
movie so but I am so excited to see that
it is so much shy to say this I mean we
got our returning favorites we got old
foes becoming you know heroes now they
are introducing classic Marvel
characters lassic Kurt Russell for
rustling I mean can we ask for any more
this is going to be great this is going
to grip and the first person who
commented about this video dela you seen
telega seen your rock star you requested
this it's gonna happen I talk to ya seen
a little bit on chat with on the
livestream I did the other day I thought
Delia scene was a woman this whole time
because he's been commenting for quite a
long time and I thought you were a woman
and I'm sorry and now he knows better
now I know but it is I'm still kind of
hoping you're a woman no longer going to
assume genders unless it makes my ego
feel better to know i have a loyal
female sub like you tella thank you that
makes it ego thanks Jimmy Kimmel for all
the help of the officers and with the
guardians of the galaxy if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects because why dregg's because
you can become a reject a knife let's
get accept-reject tonight right I need a
stargazer I mean it will be alive for
one more hour and then unless you
subscribe to her Channel wow he doesn't
get at least 25 more subscribers in the
next hour of this video being uploaded
this knife will be stabbed into her
jugular to subscribe to her channel I
think he's actually serious
okay I mean maybe if a hundred of you
subscribed that would like you know he
would never threaten me again we'll see
like I don't know like the threat per 25
you can just give this is just even it
out at 100 leave it at that
ever difference again I'm actually being
threatened with why do you live done it
is done you're fine I'm done you know
what's it I know you won't subscribe
may not you everybody